bunch of teammates about the team to
five your journey and just kind of
capsulated all that into you know what's
happening right now I mean feel great
you know to go to war with those guys
every single night you know through
through everything we went through this
year I you know you look at some of the
stuff that's going on it's like oh that
was two years ago and I was like five
months ago you know seven months ago two
months ago
like everything this team has been
through them extremely proud of the guys
you know the way we fought you know it's
great but you know we lost there's no
moral victories you know congratulations
to Toronto I don't you know they played
a great series and they deserve to win
back here on the Left Drive on Nick free
Delia's p.m. just following up on that
how much solace are you guys able to
take now and maybe in the months ahead
at the way in which you fought in these
last few games short as short-handed as
you were with KD and clay and everybody
battling injuries I mean you know
obviously you feel good about it but you
know it's no shocker to us you know we
know what this team has been made of all
along and I've said it over and over
again you know the pretty offense will
always be the storyline but this team
you know kind of heart you know
everybody step on that floor display a
ton of horror so you know it's no
shocker does that we continue to fight
but like I said we came up a little
short that's that's just it
there on the center CJ CJ Peters in the
San Francisco Examiner
Tremont's Steve said earlier that you
know just considering all the injuries
you guys faced he was you know shocked
you guys were in this position you know
able to do you know you guys's
wherewithal and be able to come back and
do all this considering all that do you
guys think you guys may be left some
opportunities out there eight missed
free throws obviously the shot at the
end of the game or stuff it didn't hit
it do you think you guys maybe left some
stuff out there I think every game you
leave something out there you know I
don't think anyone leaves any game and
feel like you you did everything you
could have possibly done to the tea you
know that's just a part of well you know
the game that we play obviously the
missed free throws you know they usually
come back and bite you they probably did
but there were several things that went
on throughout the course of this game
which is why we lost so you know I think
I can look at every loss in my career
and every win and nitpick you know today
we lost next seed oh yeah dream on Jeff
Ferraro Bay Area News Group can you talk
about Klay Thompson's performance what
you saw when he went down and just how
much it hurt you guys to not have him
the rest of the game oh I mean well you
know when when out of clay stuff you
know it takes some shooting off the
floor you know so spacing is not quite
there obviously one of our best
defenders you know and probably the guy
who got the most heart on his team you
know oh it's not really the most popular
opinion but you know as a guy who's been
with clay for seven years I don't know
many people with as much heart as clay
so you know the way he was playing as
aggressive as he was you know he was he
was carrying us and you know when he
went down obviously you know is we lose
a lot but did you know it was just to
shoot the free throws or did you think
clays coming back he's gonna play some
more oh I know it was just to shoot the
free throws but also with clay he would
if they would have let him stay off
they're able to stay that's just who he
is you see trying to run back down a
floor like what are you doing
but that's clay how many people was
going to play with a hamstring injury no
one like no one does that so that's just
who he is man that guy is uh he's a
warrior and obviously does you know no
pun intended with that but
it's no other way to describe him you
know he's gonna give everything he got
every time we step on the floor and even
some things that he don't have which is
else he was gonna try to give him more
that's just who he is that's why we love
him
Steve on the right side fourth row
burner nba.com there's been in end of
the run heir to a lot of the coverage
and and discussion even tonight but some
version of you guys is going to show up
in the fall and step back out on the
court will you be dragging an
accumulation of wear and tear what do
you expect is next for your group yeah I
think everybody thinks it's kind of end
of us this is not smart we're not done
yet you know we we lost this year
clearly this is what in our year you
know but solder cookie crumbles
sometimes well yeah all that jazz I
don't see it happening dough would be
back final two questions in the front
and in the back here
Tremont ristic Rick USA today just to go
back on clay I don't know I just be
curious to know if you know this did you
know he was doing jumping jacks in the
tunnel and trying to run back and forth
no I didn't but it does not shock me one
bit you know clay is he's crazy to say
the least you know he is going he loved
to play basketball and no matter what
he's got he's going to try to be out
there on the floor so it's not shocking
at all and I'm sure he tried to get back
out on the floor and they just would not
let him and so you know it sucks
obviously we're praying that everything
is okay but that's a tough one last
question back right
hey dream on Rick diddle with 95 7 the
game and sports byline knowing that if
you got another tee you were gonna miss
potential game 7 did you
adjust your game at all was it on your
mind or did you just play the same you
always do no I wasn't on my mind I'm not
an idiot I know that I can't get another
tee so I'm not really gonna flirt that
line you know I think you know if you
look at you know this entire year there
was a lot of noise about players and
officiating and back and forth and and I
think over the course the last eight to
ten weeks that all has been cleaned up
you know from both sides of fishy
officials I think we're a lot better and
communicating with us and I think
players in turn showed the same respect
to those guys so you know I had some
conversations with officials today and
but you know that's allowed I think you
know there's kind of this narrative of
we don't work together we all work
together to put a great product out
there on the floor and represent this
lead the way we all wanted to be
represented as we all are part of the
makeup of this league so you know I had
conversations with officials but yeah
I'm far from donors people think I am
you know I know I control myself attack
just a little bit Thank You Jane I
appreciate all your orders here it's
been great you know y'all have done a
great job of helping grow this game so
thanks to everything god do for
everything thank you